en ce moment aux causes du courant des
virus et les qu'énergie 12 à
déprogrammer la saison 2 des anges et a
choisi de rediffuser la saison 5 de
l'émission c'est à dire la saison 5
c'était celle de 2013 et celle où il y
avait quatre piscines adam notre chéri
ou encore nabil a bien sûr que j'adore
vous le savez je m'en suis jamais caché
j'adore nabil et on a pu revoir des
moments cultes de nabila on regarde et
on a pu revoir la phrase qui l'a rendue
célèbre
non mais alors quoi voilà sans fin on se
rappelle de sa regarder où tu veux leur
ramener un parfum d'histoire un
shampoing l'info sur toile c'est les
boules rompre un fait c'est n'importe
quoi
bah oui ce sont marc machin truc
personnel dans ce cas là apparemment
c'était aurélie et capucine qui révèle
jean brun
alou non mais à l'eau quand
tu es une fille de la ba de shampoing
allô allô
je suis prêt à vous me re sauver
tu es une fille tap atx ou francs c'est
comme si je saisis at any fille dabbachi
[Musique]
elle est toujours aussi belle un habile
arena direct on m'a aussi inquiétait
déjà beau gosse notre thomas oui eh ben
ça matin une info là-dessus je crois que
c'est un petit peu grincer des dents du
côté des candidats parce qu'ils n'ont
pas été informés qu'ils allaient
rediffusé et comme ils sont pas payés je
pense qu'il ya quelques lettres papier
bleu qui vont partir chez le producteur
a mon avis tu ailles dag dag dag abbaoui
gallet malo slibard quand tu reçois des
gens de lettres là je peux te dire que
tu alcibar qu'il chante ou et là où il a
sorti les chéris il y avait un habile à
kiev sous ce qui avait sorti une phrase
de ouf aussi lors de la diffusion de
cette saison là avait elle avait une
autre idée que nous à propos de la date
de la guerre
regardez ça mieux rentrer dans la maison
aurélie elle arrive et là c'est la
guerre mondiale de 78
et la guerre mondiale de 78 tchador